[Music]
when we look at the clients that we're
dealing with the key problems that
they're facing are around how do they
maintain their IT infrastructure while
also adding value to the business to
allow those organizations to focus their
IT people on key skills and key
activities that the business will value
they need to be able to move their
current workloads into that cloud
context without a massive investment
when we looked at that seamless
transition without conversion we wanted
to have a VMware based cloud solution
and clearly IBM cloud with this bare
metal server offering where we can run a
complete VMware stack allows us to
protect our client workloads onto a
VMware platform with zero conversion of
the source a virtual machine and allow
them to run up life in the cloud and
also revert back to non premise after
any incident that has happened the
entire experience is completely seamless
to the client and ensures that they have
minimal downtime and minimum potential
disruption to their organization in a
disaster recovery solution typically
clients would have done sort of big
buying tests once or twice a year where
they look at bringing large swift's of
their technology live to test that it's
followed and then they'd shut it down
again very time-intensive it was very
invasive to the day-to-day operations of
most organizations what our clients are
now doing is on an ongoing basis
moving workloads to the cloud and
allowing them to run for a period of
days or weeks in a live context and then
reverting them back to their original
location and treating the cloud presence
as a extension of their on premise
environment and that's giving them a
huge amount of flexibility about how
they approach disaster recovery planning
and certainty on on the functionality of
their systems
[Music]
iBM is an organization have been
incredibly supportive the consistency of
the behavior of the speed of delivery
the skill that we can achieve with IBM
Cloyd these are things we couldn't do
previously and these are elements of a
complex IT ecosystem that we are
exposing to our clients in a way that
wasn't possible previously
[Music]